what inspired you to want to write a
book the laws of human nature well you
know each of my books kind of comes at a
historical moment so the 48 laws of
power was at a moment where I think
people were being really hypocritical
about power there were a lot of
self-help books out there that were so
soft and gentle and like everything is
sort of Pollyannish about power and you
just need to be positive and have an
open attitude to be nice to people and
you'll get ahead and it really pissed me
off because my experiences in Hollywood
it elsewhere and in in in all the
different jobs I've had is that's not
what the world is like so I felt angry
and when I'm angry I write a book mmm
and so mastery I was really angry
because I thought people don't know how
to make things anymore they're so techno
obsessed they're so into their
algorithms they're so think they can get
anything easily or quickly and we're
gonna find ourselves in a world where
bridges are gonna fall apart people
don't know how to design things or make
things or write a book anymore and I was
really worried about it so I wrote I was
angry so I wrote mastery so the laws of
human nature I think we've lost a sense
of psychology of what really motivates
people I think people were living in
times where people have never been more
self-obsessed so more self-absorbed for
whatever reasons there was like there
may be a little bit social media plays a
huge role in that and so people are kind
of locked into their own little world
you may not realize this but I think
that the source of most of the pain that
people feel in their life the source of
most of their failures in life why they
hit a wall why they can't get any
further in life is because they don't
understand people they don't understand
what motivates they can't get inside the
mind of the other person they're always
thinking of themselves and because of
that they're they don't have the ability
to persuade or influence people to get
them to move in the direction they want
their relationships with people are very
thin and brittle there's no real deep
empathic connection specifically to
today's times as which was yes got it
it's getting worse and worse out there
but also a lack of
a self-awareness as you were pointing
out at the beginning everyone thinks
it's the other person that's
narcissistic or aggressive or is envious
or has a dark side or is repressed or is
short side not me know so a lack of a
self-awareness and the lack of what
really motivates people and I encounter
it all the time I do a lot of consulting
with very high-powered people in
business in politics all over the world
you would go along to the Middle East
for a month because somebody was hiring
you to help him out with decisions they
were making yeah and I was always
shocked at how they could be so smart
about some things but be absolutely
ignorant about people like they hired
somebody who ended up being the partner
who stole the company as if a person
like that doesn't leave traces behind
them in their past and they were going
to do that you know on and on and on I
could give you a hundred different
stories at the same thing so I'm always
shocked at how people don't have a sense
of the psychology of the people they're
dealing with they don't know how to
judge people's character they're basing
their opinions of people on their
appearance whether someone's charming or
good-looking or articulate and they're
not looking behind this behind the
surface behind the mask so that anger
kind of fueled this book and was sort of
one of the main reasons I wrote it